oh never in a million years you've
lost your mind what the hell is that
have you guys lost it no sir
[Music]
yes my peoples is chunks and this is
snack wars for lad bible
i'll be playing soccer this year and
it's going to be england versus the rest
of the world
voila no
i hate the good onions i think i'm gonna
vomit
all right cool so this looks
this looks like a mess what's this
that's horrible pickled sour bamboo
shoot slices
but i'm not going to attempt to open
this
is there a bucket well that the the
textures for me
it tastes like a dog's tongue
no not me one second let's try one more
time
i'd rather a pickled onion ah
i'm lying for bamboo honestly
i hate this so much bamboo every day of
the week
so i know what crackers are oh
oh never in a million years you've
lost your mind what the hell is that
have you guys lost it no sir
that is dreadful oh my god
what is this
[Music]
i've lost my appetite for three days is
this an english thing fashion
what's wrong with the old-fashioned
gentleman's round
there's nothing gentlemen about that and
then what's this
yjx fried yellow croco with salted black
beans
oh that's that's a bad whiff that's a
bad wave
what's that oh no
i've got those eyes for a second it's
the black bean
oh that's that is dreadful guys
this is horrible that oh
oh i thought it didn't tell me i'm
actually scared now
look at this
no that one
that was a joke it was a prank that
whole thing was a prank ha ha i got you
guys
i'll be honest with you guys today call
is one of my
favorite favorite things oh god get me a
milk and i think i can get through three
of these
look at him he's looking all pretty
you've really done it today man
just getting today stuck in here
we know i love this
okay i'll be ruby this has to be update
come on guys
i've seen what they tried to do they
have to respect it
you tried what you felt feels like um
spit and they just got like some sand on
it
they tried they you know i mean we're
gonna go we're gonna go back to the
cherry baker
to help them prove the taste yeah now
it's better
definitely not bad but we're going to
give that to
england voila
oh lovely chubby great smell it's just
you know i mean this is
you know what you're getting with this
yeah
we're going for days i'm gonna move on
into something i haven't seen before
plum tim chips all right cool let's
actually
get into this
yeah he tried to do it simple it didn't
work it didn't work
after eight minutes i'm trying to open
that
it has that taste where you're liking
there and then after like seven
bites you're like actually yeah keep
going for this
i like this don't love it i'm gonna go
for the kp
original salted nuts but these are nice
as well they both come with me
so the winner was
you know it was england there you go yes
[Applause]
make sure you like comment and subscribe
i've been chunks and that's been snack
wars with chunks
[Music]
wow very big well
oh bro what that smells like [ __ ] ass
am i eating ass juice what is this
nigeria what are you doing